let's go to our next caller from the 207
area code now if I recall correctly 207
is the Portland Maine area although I'm
not totally sure 207 caller tell us your
name where you're calling from and
what's on your mind today
I David this is Terrence I'm calling
from the Portland Maine area so you're
correct
thank you and they're here and I just
want to keep maybe the show light and
maybe you could have this as a new
segment where it's celebrities and their
doppelgangers or look-alike and I'll
start the first one with hopefully I
won't get assassinated but have you ever
noticed that Melania Trump and Jenner
look alike you're talking about Caitlyn
Jenner Caitlyn Jenner could be a twin
for Melania Trump you know that's not
that crazy that's not that crazy yeah
what other ones you got here Terrence
the other one would be for you okay and
I think that you could be a stunt double
for Kirk Cameron yeah I've heard that
before
I don't really see it I don't really see
it I know some people do I mean I was
born with really curly hair I don't know
if he still has it I think on growing
pains he had the curly hair I my hair
has gone straight I get the ones I
commonly get our Kirk Cameron the male
porn star James Dean of course the guy
who plays all gosh who the guy who plays
mr. Shue in glee Joseph gordon-levitt
those are the ones I get most often yeah
I think Kirk Cameron makes sense to all
right I did know Ray Comfort yeah that's
true that's a fair point yeah you have
any fur Cat Cora I just want to say I
appreciate for a pet cats got his own
style and you know you just can't
duplicate you know perfection like way
to go Pat you're your own all right
Sally Sally Kohn is one that tad has
gotten a bunch of time the longest time
I thought I didn't have one I died I
didn't have a tally cone yeah yeah
all right Terrence we'll listen we will
invert it and we will get you guys work
and thanks for everything you do look up
put up the two by two of Melania and
Kate
then and see how many responses you get
we will do that we will do that all
right Terrence thanks very much always
great to hear from our friendly
neighbors to the north of Maine mostly
friendly although Maine has some pretty
rural areas where they are hard right
like full hard right that's it for calls
for this week we will take calls again
that I promise you